[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 culture tout de
suite le sommaire depuis le 19 septembre
le musée d'archéologie nationale
accueille l'exposition d'alyzia rome
l'installation retrace l'aventuré
archéologique de napoléon iii
au programme un maquette peinture
sculpture ou encore tablettes
interactives et comme chaque année la
commanderie fait nuit blanche pour cette
nouvelle édition de nombreuses
animations sont prévues
expositions vidéos oeuvres interactives
accroc danse le directeur artistique
frédéric solé nous présentera son
spectacle
et puis le festival de bd revient au
château de buc est les 10 et 11 octobre
pour cette 27ème édition dédicaces
rencontres avec les auteurs et
exposition vous attendent
anissa tamini d'écart nous parlera de
l'événement et je vous le disais tout à
l'heure depuis le 19 septembre
l'exposition d'alésia à rome s'est
installée au musée d'archéologie
nationale à saint germain en laye un
parcours qui retraçait les prémices de
l'archéologie sous napoléon iii
un reportage de d'astrid bergère et mary
bale train
l'exposition présente les débuts de
l'archéologie sous napoléon iii
passionné il a financé des fouilles en
france en méditerranée en afrique du
nord mais aussi en italie entre 1861 et
1870 son but était notamment d'écrire un
livre sur jules césar
ces fouilles vont permettre un apollon 3
de recueillir un certain nombre de
données et un certain nombre de matériel
archéologique qui vont lui permettre de
documenter donc la figure de ce général
romain et donc de mieux documenter donc
son ouvrage des maquettes des peintures
sculptures moulage et tablettes
interactives sont présents dans
l'exposition
tout cela permet de mieux connaître une
autre personnalité de napoléon iii
mais l'objet central de l'exposition
c'est la photographie la photographier
va devenir l'auxiliaire de l'archéologie
elle va ainsi apporter la preuve du réel
jusqu'à présent les fouilleurs est bien
faisait des dessins mais le dessin
pouvait être interprétée dresser des
cartes mais ces cartes
être mauvaise tout simplement là pour la
première fois la photo va apporter la
preuve des dires la preuve des
déclarations donc elle devient vraiment
dominante
vous avez jusqu'au 3 janvier pour venir
découvrir ses oeuvres exposées au musée
d'archéologie nationale est comme chaque
année la nuit blanche revient à la
commanderie
de nombreux rendez vous sont prévus pour
l'occasion et parmi les propositions
artistiques
la compagnie le grand jeté donnera deux
représentations de son spectacle
réplique clé en avril à 2019 de la crau
danse sur le thème de l'interprétation
des gestes à travers à la réplique
frédéric solé directeur artistique de la
compagnie nous présente le spectacle
moi j'ai vraiment envie que le spectacle
porte une notion d'espoir est une notion
de joie de vivre et de joie de vivre en
commun en fait de façon collectif et
pour ne peut pas avancer sans l'autre on
est obligé d'avancer avec vous
[Musique]
on a une scénographie qui est vraiment
particulière
il y à des rails qui sont posés au sol
qui font lui m de diamètre et il y a
deux cubes motorisés sur ses rails
ces pubs en fait les danseurs vont en
tournée tout le temps quasiment durant
le long du spectacle
et puis vont essayer de trouver leur
équilibre
le jeu avec l'autre et puis ensuite le
déséquilibre pour qu' il ya une question
en fait qui domine dans ce spectacle
c'est si je tombe
est ce que tu es là pour moi forcément
ça commence assez lentement puis avec le
jeu avec l'interprétation
ça va de plus en plus vite donc du coup
le danger
le risque est de plus en plus grande
c'est quelque chose aussi combat on
partage avec le public puisqu'il ya un
moment donné dans le spectacle qu'ils
vont être au milieu alors avec les
règles sanitaires actuelles sans toucher
le public mais en tout cas il est pris à
partie il est pris dans le jeu pour
aller un peu plus loin et dans leurs
relations et dans la pièce sur
l'interactivité
les représentations auront lieu dans la
cour de la commanderie à 21h et 22h30 et
d'autres rendez-vous vous attendent pour
cette nuit blanche à la commanderie le
samedi 3 octobre de 20h à minuit
notamment une exposition vidéo donnez
moi une minute de dorian bélanger doria
bélanger a dansé au bâtiment des garde
il y aura aussi babel installé à la
chapelle une sculpture éphémère
il y aura également une oeuvre
interactive qui sera visible dans la
cour une projection qui renvoie à
l'imaginaire et puis la composition
stellaire les enfants des étoiles sera à
découvrir dans le grand atelier
le festival de duke revient les 10 et 11
octobre de 10h à 18h prix de 25 auteurs
sont a rencontré sur place
objectif de cette 27e édition de rendre
cet art accessible à tous
anissa tamini d'écart la directrice des
affaires culturelles de la ville elle
nous parle de l'événement
on a travaillé beaucoup avec les enfants
malades les handicapés les prisonniers
les adolescentes décrochage l'idée c'est
d'utiliser en fait ce festival et la
bande dessinée comme un outil et c'est
un outil redoutable pour essayer de
conquérir ou d'aller vers des publics
contre le cas qui n'ont pas accès à la
culture
on va trouver l'équivalent de 25 auteurs
qui ont répondu présent dont qui seront
là à des marchands des marchands donc
qui qui amène tout un toute une panoplie
de bd et de et de goodies et tout ce qui
est en lien avec la bd notre libraire
officielle qui sera là alors des
animations un caricaturiste des
expositions beaucoup d'auteurs ne
viendront pas notamment ceux qui
viennent de l'étranger parce que les
auteurs viennent du monde entier
donc on en a beaucoup qui ne vont pas
pouvoir venir non pas faute de ne pas
vouloir venir mais ils ne pourront pas à
cause de la fermeture des frontières et
donc en fait on revient presque
aux basiques c'est à dire que ça va être
un festival franco belge en 2009 si mes
souvenirs sont bons
le festival a été transféré au château
de buc qui est un site qui représente un
peu l'histoire de deux buts par rapport
à les 14 et donc l'idée c'était de faire
venir les gens et de leur raconter aussi
l'histoire du lieu la 16e édition de
parcours d'artiste aura lieu les 3 4 10
et 11 octobre l'événement annuel est
organisé par l'association hélium
le public pourra découvrir gratuitement
les artistes de la vallée de chevreuse
les samedi et dimanche de 11h à 19h pour
en parler sur ce plateau célia gars
tsongo bonsoir soir est la carte du
parcours elle est assez vaste cette
année oui elle compte 59 lieu
d'exposition répartis sur 32 villes et
villages de la vallée de chevreuse en
yvelines et aussi en essonne en tout il
y aura 90 artistes dont 80 sont membres
de l'association hélium donc c'est une
association créée en 2004 qui promeut
l'art dans cette vallée alors ce sera
difficile de voir tous les artistes
donc c'est à chacun de choisir son
itinéraire mais certains lieux sont
assez proches les uns des autres ce qui
permet une visite à pied ou à vélo et
c'est surtout important de maintenir
l'événement cette année particulièrement
cette année oui parce que la crise
sanitaire a fortement touché la culture
et c'était donc essentiel pour la
présidente de l'association de soutenir
les artistes
le parcours pour rob la majorité des
artistes d'hélium c'est c'est le premier
la première fois ils vont exposer depuis
depuis qu'on filme en fait on peut c'est
vrai que les artistes sont comme d'une
manière générale en général assez
précarisés donc forcément l'acrylique au
vide
c'est pour certains c'est assez
difficile effectivement là c'est très
très important pour beaucoup d'artistes
et on compte sur le public puisque l'on
compte sur la solidarité du public en
fait au gnr devenir les voix de venir
les soutenir
s il y aura tout et d'artistes présents
des peintres des sculpteurs des graveurs
des photographes et j'en fasse tous les
arts seront représentés alors qu'on
s'est rendu à nos
le château dans l'atelier d'agnès est ce
qu'en ski père qui peint beaucoup
d'abstrait avec peu de couleurs elle
espère lors de ce parcours d'artiste
renouer avec le public
et l'année dernière elle a quand même
reçu plus de 200 visiteurs de pendant
ces deux outils end j'ai besoin du
regard sur mon travail
on en est tellement solitaire dans ce
qu'on fait on y met totalement toute son
énergie toute son âme j'ai envie de dire
que rester complètement seul c'est une
une frustration aussi le travail d'un
peintre effet quand même pour être
montrées pour être vu mais c'est bien
vous êtes allés aussi dans un autre
atelier à saint germain de la grange
chez laurence de saint martin qui est
sculptrice et graveur elle a rejoint
l'association en janvier 2020 pour moi
c'était vraiment important d'intégrer
cette association qui à peu près une
centaine d'artistes parce que on a
besoin de sortir de son atelier on a
besoin de rencontrer d'autres artistes
on a besoin d'être parfois encadré est
de faire de belles rencontres pour
pouvoir exposer avec d'autres personnes
laurence de saint-martin ali des
sentiments avec des idées sur des
gravures
ce sont des travaux très originaux où le
public a forcément un avis sur ces
oeuvres
j'ai envie de de discuter de ça et de
vous peut avoir plusieurs avis j'ai
envie aussi de susciter une émotion
c'est important donc rencontré on n'a
pas des oeuvres sans public en fait je
trouve qu'elle trouve son éclat et sa
raison d'être parce qu'elle est regardée
et mon seul regard ne suffit pas je suis
juge et partie cette année en complément
des visites des animations et des
lectures seront proposés vous pouvez
retrouver le programme complet sur
hélium tirer artistes 30 me merci c'est
bien de nous avoir présenté l'événement
on retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau 7,8 culture
avec plaisir après des mois d'arrêt du
conduit au confinement le cabaret du
bout des prêts
à cerner la ville a rouvert ses portes
le 26 septembre avec un nouveau
spectacle cabaret quatre saisons la
revue musicale présentation de cette
comédie musicale par le responsable
tunisien au micro d'astrid bergère le
cabaret la rouvre le 26 septembre
enfin alors que le confinement comment
vous vous sentez j'avais il ya encore
une semaine je me sentais un peu lourd
est là depuis la reprise des répétitions
je me sens bien physiquement et surtout
très heureux de reprendre parce que on
était un peu comme comme des enfants
devant un sapin de noël sans pouvoir
ouvrir les cadeaux voilà et donc là vous
ouvrez avec un spectacle une comédie
musicale
alors si midi musical qui nous fait
chanter qui nous donne un petit peu
envie de danser
ce que vous nous en parler qui est mario
quelle est l'histoire marque je joue le
rôle de mario qui est le propriétaire
d'une pizzeria est en fait mario est un
est une fleur bleue
qui tombe amoureux de la danseuse du
cabaret du bout des prix qui est juste à
côté de sa pizzeria et forcément il a
promis d'offrir la pizza quatre saisons
à celle qu'il aime
voilà donc il se peut que la carte soit
garni s'il arrive à séduire cette
fameuse la lie voilà et les chants les
musiques où on peut alors ça se passe
dans les années 60 donc forcément le
thème et les thèmes musicaux sont
beaucoup de titres des années 60 et
aussi quelques compositions
qu'on a voulu qu'on a voulu intégrer
pour pouvoir aussi donner au public des
nouveautés pour l'oreille voilà pour le
fun c'était bien l'intégralité de
l'émission si on s'en sortait présenté
par astrid vergeer est à retrouver sur
le site tv 78 point fr michael gregorio
sera de passage dans les yvelines la
semaine prochaine l'humoriste se
produira à la ferme du mané le samedi 9
octobre on regarde un extrait de son
dernier spectacle j'ai dix ans
[Musique]
jean les couilles
pour l'achat
[Musique]
quand
encore lapin le
non
c'est la fin de ce numéro du 7-8 culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro et de nouvelles sorties
culturelles
bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]